nos piden simplificar la raíz cúbica de
27 a cuadrada b elevada a la quinta se
cúbica y el objetivo cuando estás
extrayendo una raíz cúbica es analizar
la expresión que tenemos dentro el
radical y extraer de cada término
aquello que sea un cubo perfecto aquello
que sea una expresión elevada a la
potencia 3 para poder extraer la raíz
cúbica de esos cubos perfectos sacarlos
del radical y dejando dentro el radical
lo que no sea cubo perfecto veamos qué
podemos hacer empecemos con 27 quizá
pueda reconocer que es un cubo perfecto
pero de no ser así puedes descomponerlo
en factores primos 27 lo podemos
escribir entonces como 3 por 9 y 9 lo
vamos a escribir como 3 por 3
así la factorización de 27 es 3 por 3
por 3 27 es exactamente 3 al cubo vamos
a describir entonces esta expresión aquí
abajo en términos de cubos perfectos 27
lo podemos escribir como 3 elevado a la
potencia 3 3 al cubo a cuadrada si
hubiera sido a kubica podríamos
extraerlo pero aquí
no podemos extraerlo de esta raíz cúbica
así es que voy a ponerlo por acá podemos
escribirlo en cualquier orden es un
producto estoy voy a poner por acá a
cuadrada ve a la quinta ve a la quinta
no es un cubo perfecto pero la podemos
escribir como un cubo perfecto x algo
que no es un cubo perfecto ve a la
quinta la podemos escribir como de
kubica por b cuadrada si quieres ver
explícitamente esto ve quinta podemos
escribirlo como b por d por b por b por
de cinco veces estos primeros tres son
claramente de kubica y estos segundos 2
son b cuadrada entonces ve a la quinta
lo podemos escribir como be cúbica de
kubica lo voy a hacer en el mismo color
púrpura b cúbica y eso multiplicado por
be cuadrada no importa el orden como lo
ponemos pues estamos haciendo productos
y finalmente tenemos se cúbica lo va a
hacer en azul que es claramente un cubo
perfecto se ha elevado a la potencia
se cúbica lo ponemos aquí del lado de
los cubos perfectos se ubica y todo esto
bajo ese signo es radical estamos aún
tomando la raíz cúbica de todo esto y
esto
aplicando propiedades de los exponentes
o más bien aplicando propiedades de los
radicales es igual a bueno estamos con
la raíz cúbica de un producto es lo
mismo que primero saquemos la raíz
cúbica de cada uno de los términos y
luego hagamos el producto ahora podría
tomar la raíz cúbica de cada uno de los
términos o pueda tomar la raíz cúbica de
3 al cubo por d al cubo por si al cubo
de hecho hagámoslo de las dos maneras
así es que separando términos que
tenemos tenemos la raíz cúbica de 3 al
cubo por la raíz cúbica de cúbica voy a
mantener el color dejamos el mismo color
para que los identifiquemos
la raíz cúbica
de c
kubica la raíz cúbica de ese cúbica y
por estos términos no me voy a separar
no podemos extraer una raíz cúbica de
ellos así es que nos va a poner juntos
en un solo radical la raíz cúbica de a
cuadrada va a mantener los colores para
que podamos identificar los d a cuadrada
por d cuadrada y podría haber separado
esto como la raíz cúbica de a cuadrada
por la raíz cúbica de cuadrada pero eso
no va a simplificar más la expresión y
ahora analizando cada término por
separado aquí que tenemos la raíz cúbica
de 3 al cubo la raíz cúbica de 27 eso va
a ser claramente 3 3 al cubo la raíz
cúbica de 3 al cubo es obvio que es 3
aquí que tenemos la raíz cúbica de b
kubica la raíz cúbica de kubica es
simplemente b luego la raíz cúbica de c
kubica esto es
voy a poner en el mismo azul vamos el
mismo azul para poner esto se ya hemos
simplificado la expresión esto es igual
a 3 por b
por se por la raíz cúbica de a cuadrada
de cuadrada la raíz cúbica de a cuadrada
de cuadrada y hemos terminado debemos
concluir la simplificación y lo que voy
a hacer ahora es dado que lo mencioné
mostrarte la otra manera resolver esto y
esto de aquí esta expresión de aquí la
podemos escribir como 3 por b por c
-todo elevado al cubo si estoy elevando
al cubo cada uno de estos y luego
haciendo el producto esto es lo mismo
que haga primero el producto y luego
eleve al cubo estoy aplicando las
propiedades básicas de los exponentes
así es que podemos escribir esto como la
raíz cúbica de tres veces elevado al
cubo por la raíz cúbica de a cuadrada de
cuadrada y ahora extrayendo la raíz
cúbica de aquí esto es claramente 3 x b
x c que multiplica a la raíz cúbica de a
cuadrada de cuadrada no identifique los
términos con colores pues ya lo habíamos
hecho eso aquí antes lo que quería
mostrarte es que este otro camino que
seguimos aquí es una opción que es
válida pues al final de cuentas nos
lleva a la misma respuesta